is six for nine at the foul line  [Applause]  missed it falls up corners got it puts  it up and it goes and milwaukee is in  front  boston takes their last timeout  an offensive rebound  and bobby portis  gives the bucks the lead with 11.4  remaining  series tied at two apiece marcus smart  goes to the rack and blocked by drew  holliday he throws it off smart  milwaukee ball  what a play by drew holiday  that is a great defensive play there  coming off to help connaughton's beat  drew holiday not only the block but the  presence of mine to throw the ball off  of  smart possession milwaukee wow  a game in a series that has been defined  by  great defensive moments walkie ball  what a play by drew holiday  that is a great defensive play there  coming off to help connaughton's beat  drew holiday not only the block but the  presence of mine to throw the ball off  of smart  possession milwaukee wow  a game in a series that has been defined  by  great defensive moments